مره حوالي شهر ونصف على وقوع زلزال تركيا
وسوريا المدمر ولا تزال اعراضه لم تدج
لبعده بشكل كلي فالكثير من سكان تركيا
يعيشون حاله الرعب في ظل تداول الشائعات
عن امكانيه حدوث زلزال مدمر اخر وتحديدا
في مدينه اسطنبول مخاوف سكان مدينه
اسطنبول تتنامى شيئا فشيئا وهو ما تفعلت
معه سلطات المدينه بتكليف عشرات الفرق
المختصه بفحص المباني لتحديد مدى قدرتها
على مقاومه الزلزال ومنذ ان وقع زلزال
مطلع شهر فبراير الماضي اتصل اكثر من 140
الف شخص ببلديه اسطنبول من اجل فحص
مبانيهم ويجول 50 فريقا من المهندسين
المدينه لفحص المباني واذا خلصوا الى ان
خطرا انهيارها مرتفع جدا فانهم يتخذون
قرارا بهدمها وقد يؤدي زلزال بقوه 7.5
درجات الى انهيار حوالي 100 الف مبنى وذلك
نقلا
عن مختصين